so a fellow leaned over i don't look to
him he had
nice clear blue eyes he just looked too
sharp i said he's
t-e-a-r-f-b-i-c-i or something really
that big fellow sitting there he looked
like rex tillerson
where did you guys take off from again
san pedro sula honduras san pedro sula
okay
it's over on the caribbean side okay
death capital of the world for some
years
the what the death capital the murder
council murder capital of the world for
a
good
remember years late some years back but
at that time it was
laid back and wonderful but a nice
halfway stop coming up
so when i said that he leaned over and
said you fly these things i said i got a
few hours mister
my name barry seal how you doing and so
then he got to talking to me and we
talked to airplanes and so forth he said
i just got out of prison this morning in
honduras
i got caught down here i didn't believe
him one bit
and he said that he had been a trans
world airline uh
captain and that it was i don't believe
he told me he was
xci but commercial yeah he was flew 747
i believe he was the youngest 747 pilot
that the
twa ever had and he took a load of
explosives
down to the uh cuban contras and got
caught with a dc-6
loaded with 10 tons of explosives and he
lost his job with a
twa so then he's working doing whatever
you can like this freelance and he got
in trouble
so i didn't believe him a bit but we
chatted about airplanes all the way on
the new one he straight up just told you
this on the airplane
that i just got out of prison this
morning you know blind explosives to
he got caught with 100 kilos in a little
piper okay
down there and he served a year okay i
didn't believe it a bit i thought he's
just trying to pull me out
so when we landed in new orleans i shook
hands with him a nice fella
and got out there and here's 20 or 30
people
women and children hanging on him crying
and begging hugging his neck and
i thought that guy's telling the truth
ain't no way he could stay sat
wow so i went over to him and
had mario to write our name and address
and the phone number on it and i said
barry i might have some work for you if
you're interested
come up see me in santa barbara all
right i'll do it
so a week or two later he comes out and
i had a
didn't learn his lesson huh well he's
ready to make some money oh yeah
so i said i'm hauling cocaine out of
columbia
and would you be interested oh yeah
let's see what you can do with flying
i didn't know what kind of pilot people
all kind of policy people get the
license still can't fly i don't right
so i had a what was your biggest concern
with him
when uh he came out to meet you in santa
barbara and you were
talking to and you were talking about
hiring him what were you worried were
you worried about anything like
like obviously his flying skills or like
were you did you have any sort of
suspicion that he could have been
cia or undercover or anything or not
after that not out now
i found out he was already in prison and
all that sort of stuff he just okay they
don't do that too
i was comfortable with him okay i really
like barry he was my friend we you know
he'd eat it all for some people
all right we were just like you guys got
a longer you get along good
really i liked him and uh
so i had a 690 aero turbojet arrow
commander that thing was nearly new
what's it called again uh uh arrow
commander or 6690 that's uh
six ninety six ninety b b arrow
commander
yeah and it was it had it said little
jet engines that returned propellers
that thing was fast it goes 300
something miles an hour and it goes
right on up there
wrapped with the jets for a while anyhow
he got in that thing
and i said show me what you got he said
sure enough i said yeah and it was a
little while i said
you don't have to show me no more he was
like bob hoover he just did the
i mean he was aerobatic like the blue
really oh yeah i fly
all right but that guy was like the blue
angels i mean it was just like
[Music]
like a god and then he cut the engine
and he just let it fly sideways to
sideways
until it comes hits the ground the only
person i've ever seen that is in this
air show with bob hoover the world
champion so he was that good
he was good he had a thousand parachute
jumps and in that movie they made about
america made about him it was so wrong
he was such a gentleman they had him
coming out of [ __ ] houses and women
hanging all over him
yeah that would just i never heard him
say damn he didn't smoke he didn't drink
he didn't do drugs
he was a businessman he was a pilot and
a gentleman
so after you were so impressed with his
acrobatics and his flying skills then
would you do
i should uh bury that i got a point this
plane needs tanking you know somebody he
said yep
needs what i need tanking i need it
won't go the range
oh it needs tanks in it so he said yeah
i got a
mechanic in uh meena arkansas that keeps
his mouth shut
and so i gave him ten thousand dollars
and he flew away in my new airplane
a few days later he called and said come
to my house i went to his house and it
was all tanked up
and that's when i told him you know i've
been stopping it uh
i'll hire you to fly and i'll give you
two thousand dollars a kilo
i was getting five and so he was happy
with it
and i said but now we don't need this
plane tanked well
first off we did a few loads and he
would fly down
and meet me in police at a ranch i had
an orange walk
and we would change the load over but
then it got dangerous i figured you know
we got 15 20 million dollars of cocaine
changing planes here
now we're going into jamaica uh because
i didn't mind flying out of
flying that southern end but i was
scared across the u.s border i'm not
scared but i'd
rather not fly hire it done
so uh but then i told him we can refuel
in
in
the military base in nicaragua
well he just couldn't believe it
so that that's the only time i really
ever impressed him
i said yeah and come out of bolivia out
of columbia anywhere and i had that
military base no words
just come right in they'll fuel you up
give your stake eggs and
polish your airplane you'll be on your
way really yeah
so barry flew and i mean he would fly
but he wouldn't fly another until i paid
him
so he did 500 kilos at the load and so
he was a million dollars he made
and uh a million dollars for one flight
right
and uh he hired this guy emile camp i
had to give the twenty thousand dollars
for him to go down get a meal out of the
honduran jail
and emile wasn't much of a pilot or he
could fly but he wasn't
he'd just get him around right so uh the
two of them flew together they're great
big fellas that's good and this gracious
two yo you can put 400 kilos in here
where y'all sit
but anyway he wouldn't fly without it so
uh you might like this little story he
uh
he wouldn't moan and groan until i paid
him well i didn't get paid until
they got paid so i had a pipeline coming
and
sometimes they'd owe me six or seven
million dollars
it'd take three or four weeks to for
them to get money and then i'd get
get what they did so i was paying him
before
i got paid so i was like a loss i'm i'm
back
right you're in front you're fronting
that money exactly yeah so
uh he wanted so you were you were paying
barry
uh-huh how much would you pay him on one
trip oh
two thousand dollars kilo i paid million
dollars a trip so you'd give barry a
million dollars
cash yes he would fly where
he would fly we'd we'd he'd fly out of
um where he wanted to up in arkansas or
louisiana
and he would come over to a little radio
station like where would he go where
would he fly
like to he'd fly to colombia yeah
but but we didn't know where we were
going a lot of the times
uh we would uh we would come over el
banco
it's at the forts of the magdalena river
there and uh
behind baron kia and there's a radio
station i believe it's still 7
20 a.m on your aisle and we come at 10
000 feet
circle and pretty soon there'll be a
plane you'd see it it might be already
there it'd be like usually a cessna 180.
and he'd be circling and you'd get right
behind him and you'd wiggle your wings
and
you might go 100 200 miles and you'd get
land in the jungle
oh and they would tell you where to land
they wouldn't say a word we didn't speak
we just followed that until they
followed the plane followed him where
we're going
and there was a signal they would do
with the with the wings well we just
knew it was him it just yeah
okay and uh so follow that plane did
that sometimes somehow we go the same
place but if there was a new place
we'd follow that plane that was pretty
neat and then uh you come back
stop it uh nicaragua refuel and come all
the way on he'd go
and he went to maina and this is what
so so he had the million dollars in cash
yeah i'd give him a million dollars
what would he do with that million once
he landed there i don't know so that was
just his that wasn't for his cost to buy
the cocaine or anything no we just i got
paid five thousand dollars a kilo
so i got paid two and a half million
dollars and i gave him one million
okay but wouldn't they have to give him
the all of the cash though
no they didn't give him anything okay
okay he'd just give he
all right he would land in meena
arkansas okay and then he would put it
in three different cars
okay and and every day i i had a fellow
buying me six cars a week
great big ones so he was okay okay that
was where i was confused
none of the transaction revenue is going
through the pilot at all the pilot is
just a delivery person he's a truck
driver okay
got it so but anyway he would i had
he had the drivers i didn't even want to
meet his drivers that's how
i was afraid to meet people right they
get caught they're going to tell them
they all did so exactly i had somebody
buying cars
and they buy these ltd's or the ford uh
ford or
mercury marquis and they had big trunks
we put air shocks on tires that wouldn't
go flat
new hoses boom boom and then i gave
those to the colombians
and they would be a trunk full of
cocaine and
duffel bags they'd have rattlesnakes on
it some have cow horns
that meant this one went to this one
that went to that one oh
wow so i had to just point the cars out
to my friend lito
and give him the key bam and i never
want to see that car again i said it's
going to your staff house i don't want
it back
right it's 5 dollars to you buddy oh i
said you take it to new york county
where you want to
it's it's as good as you can do so they
liked it after a while
wow so anyway
one time barry was barely aching a
little bit about might be being slow on
pace so
i was in the store and i saw these stay
free mini pads
a pretty package stay free mini pads cam
packs
oh tampons damn yeah
australia time and uh so i i got a
million dollars and put it in a box and
i put those
tampons on top of it stay free and wrap
that thing up put a bow on it
that's great barry loved it he made a
place on his mantelpiece for those
for the stay freeze that's amazing yeah
that is absolutely amazing
so how long did your and barry's
relationship last about two years
two years and a half two years uh-huh
and what when did it go south what
happened when it went off
i got arrested in august 1982.
okay that was the end of it